Apple has finally updated their MacBook Pros
for 2019, and quite a few people seem to be
confused on which configuration they should
buy, so we decided to make this video highlighting
10 mistakes you should avoid when making your
purchase.
And stick around till the end to see which
configurations we recommend for every use-case.
The first 5 mistakes have to do with the new
15” MacBook Pro, so let’s get into mistake
#1.
When buying the 8-core MacBook Pro, don’t
spend the extra $200 on the 2.4GHz CPU upgrade,
because the 2.3GHz processor is already an
i9, and in the real-world Cinebench R20 benchmark,
we got a score of 3,161 points.
Snazzy Labs tested the 2.4GHz 8-core processor
and he scored 3,231 points.
That’s only a 2% higher score for $200,
so we don’t recommend anyone to make that
upgrade.
Onto mistake #2, if you’re planning on getting
the 8-core processor, start by selecting the
$2800 model that already comes with an 8-core
instead of choosing the $2400 model and upgrading
the CPU to an 8 core.
The reason is that it makes you upgrade straight
to the 2.4GHz CPU for $300, and at that point,
you’re already at $2700 and you only get
a 256GB SSD.
Upgrading to 512 brings the price up to $2900,
so just choose the $2800 model from the very
beginning which comes with the 512GB SSD and
of course, the 8-core CPU.
For the Third mistake, don’t upgrade the
graphics if you’re a photo editor or you’re
doing work that’s heavily dependant on the
processor.
We’ve tested it many times before and upgrading
graphics literally does nothing for photo
editing, so just keep whatever graphics comes
with your configuration.
The 4th mistake that people make is not upgrading
the RAM and choosing to throw their extra
cash on something else like the processor
or graphics instead, especially for photo
editing or similar workloads.
Yes, it’s a $400 upgrade but it’s well
worth it.
We tested the 2018 MacBook Pros and found
that the biggest factor for photo editing
was actually the RAM, making a bigger difference
than even the faster i9 processor, so prioritize
RAM if you’ve got extra cash.
Now the 5th mistake is made by video editors
or graphics renderers who choose not to buy
the Vega 20 graphics.
We’ve seen massive boosts in everything
from video editing to gaming performance,
and even a small jump in processor performance
just going from Radeon 560X graphics to Vega
20.
If you’re a video editor with extra cash,
pay for Vega 20 before any other upgrade.
The only downside is that Apple makes you
buy the $2800 8-core model in order to upgrade
to Vega 20, but it’s definitely worth it.
Apple has also updated the 13” MacBook Pro
for 2019, so let’s take a look at 5 mistakes
people make when buying that model.
For Mistake #1, people don’t realize that
the $1299 and $1499 models haven’t been
updated at all since 2017, meaning they still
pack outdated 7th-gen dual-core processors
and the 2nd-gen butterfly keyboard that’s
been having so many issues recently.
It’s sad that Apple hasn’t updated it,
so we recommend going for the 2018 MacBook
Air instead if you can’t afford the $1800
2019 model.
Mistake #2 is that some people think the new
13” MacBook Pro packs Intel’s latest 9th
gen processors, but it doesn’t.
It still packs the same 8th gen processors
from before.
They’re just clocked slightly higher.
Why did Apple do this?
Well, it turns out that the 9th-gen quad-core
processors don’t come with the faster Intel
Iris Plus graphics chips which are badly needed
on this machine, so Apple just stuck with
8th gen.
If you want 9th gen, go for the 15”.
Now onto mistake #3, don’t pay the extra
$300 to go from the base i5 to i7 processor.
It really won’t make much of a difference,
at least not $300 worth.
A couple of years back, i7 meant that you
get hyper-threading, but these days i5’s
get it as well, so the only difference is
a clock speed boost, so just stick to the
base CPU on the 13”.
To avoid mistake #4, make sure to use any
extra cash you have on upgrading to 16GB of
RAM over anything else.
8GB is really low in 2019 and it’ll benefit
you in everything from web browsing to photo
and video editing, and basically everything
else, so if you’re gonna upgrade one thing,
upgrade the RAM.
However, be careful not to spec out the 13”
MacBook Pro with a bunch of upgrades, which
brings us to our final mistake.
Some people spec out the 13” with 16GB of
RAM and the faster processor for $2300, not
realizing that the $2400 15” MacBook Pro
gives you a MASSIVE improvement for only $100
more.
Yes, you get the larger 15” screen, but
you also get 16GB of faster 2400Mhz DDR4 RAM,
a much faster 9th gen 6-core processor instead
of the 8th gen 4-core, and you actually get
a dedicated graphics chip which destroys the
13-inch MacBook Pros integrated graphics.
This’ll make a huge difference for video
editors.
So with all of that out of the way, let me
give some recommendations for each use-case.
If you’re a user who does simple stuff like
web browsing, school or business work or using
web-based apps, we recommend just going for
the base $1200 2018 MacBook Air since you
won’t really be using any of the extra power
the MacBook Pro provides.
Now if you do a little bit of photo or video
editing, maybe some rendering, programming
or producing any kind of content, you’ll
definitely see the benefits of the MacBook
Pro with its very color accurate display,
extra ports and higher performance, and you
should therefore opt for the $1800 2019 MacBook
Pro, and if you have a bit more cash left
in your budget, upgrade to 16GB of RAM.
Now if you’re doing those tasks almost every
day and you take it very seriously, you should
buy the base $2400 15” MacBook Pro, especially
video editors, since you get a dedicated graphics
chip.
Photo editors should opt for 32GB of RAM if
they can since that’ll make the biggest
difference, and that’s the highest config
we recommend, you won’t really get that
much of a boost going for the 8-core.
Video editors should upgrade to 560X graphics,
and if you really want to upgrade storage
too, just go back and choose the $2800 model
instead because it brings you up to an 8-core
CPU, and already comes with 560X graphics
and 512GB of storage.
And if you really want to go all out and have
the fastest machine possible, go for the Vega
20 upgrade since it makes a huge difference
in video editing or graphically intensive
tasks.
So there you have it guys, we’ll have links
to the different configurations in the description
below, and if this video helped you out, tap
that like button and click the circle above
to subscribe so you don’t miss out on our
future videos.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!